there's a lovely study by a Stanford
psychologist called babashiv and he
serves people five different bottles of
wine each of those bottles of wine has a
prominent price label but the twist in
the experiment is there are only four
different liquids one of the wines is
repeated so sometimes people are
drinking wine thinking it costs five
dollars a bottle couple of minutes later
they have a little sample of a wine it's
exactly the same wine they think it's
different and they think it costs 45 a
bottle when shiv asks the participants
to rate the scores of those wines they
rate the same wine but they're told is
expensive 70 higher people have a rule
of thumb in their head if it's expensive
it must be high quality preserve jars
got one of those crisscross red and
white Lids on the top of it I just think
that all of these are little signals of
effort if they care this much about the
twine that they've wrapped my bam
shoulder in then surely they've gone
through the effort of this other stuff
too those expectations aren't just and
nice to have they're absolutely crucial
for a brand